hello and welcome to this video this is
the round recap video for round 10 of
the Tana steel tournament of 2016 yeah
route 10 was a pretty interesting round
but as almost all of those rounds they
had a couple of not so interesting games
and I will look through all the games
but start with them less exciting ones
and work my way up to the yam or tens
and counters so we're going to start
with Geary with white against the world
champion magnus carlsen Edd and this is
the first game so you already know that
it's not the biggest over yeah not the
biggest of a thriller to expect what did
we have we had a Queens gambit and
Magnus is going for Bishop before which
is one of his main openings nowadays he
also placed a classical quite often
Bishop to e7 but the Rogozin is more
often than not his some choice yeah
Geary goes for Bishop g5 which is
considered to be a little bit less um
testing maybe than taking at Bishop g5
one reason is that um Hume take first
and go here if black plays age six here
white actually has the option to play
Bishop h44 sharp play after g 5 and 9 24
yeah white usually goes here and we have
a sharp game ahead yeah what can
sacrifice is Pawn leads to quite
interesting play on in the game
continuation after Bishop g5 and h6 why
it does not have the option to take
sorry to play Bishop h4 because after
this it is believed to be that black has
a good play here it's a it's a
difference if this trade has happened or
not one difference is that in some cases
here h5 can be very embarrassing you
know if white now go what's naughty to
lift to show the difference there is
also
something hang on deform so ticks and
tags was played and i will give you
played Queen to be three this is a known
move it's difficult to come up with a
novelty on move seven in the Queens
gambit but it was not can not perceived
to be very dangerous usually due to c5
this is what normally is played and also
is in the spirit of the recursion cards
not ever gent with the capture and he
took a while to play that so it seems
that he yeah basically played this over
the board takes an hour c6 so a very
very solid choice here bye-bye the world
champion on the position that we get now
after you three and I think this is all
fields very logical and is this castles
Bishop d3 yeah but my meds why it may
also castle here this looks a lot like
the lusca variation of the Queens gambit
declined yeah to show you the
similarities I'm going back a little bit
just interesting how sometimes yeah
similar positions can come up from
different openings this is the this is a
position here out of the out of the
lusca defense set just to take that in
and in the game we got this position
which is very similar here the queen is
only have six instead of e7 and this is
in fact making a bit of a difference as
here c5 was played immediately in the
last scam a black sometimes goes like b6
Bishop e7 later c5 and TLC five is
playable immediately the whole own setup
here is geared towards full equality and
we see that with Bishop e7 the bishop
here gets traded and here
ready get the feeling that not much is
going to happen here yeah just got
traded yeah takes with the Jeep on to
keep the c5 pawn covered in toc c70 it
is pretty clear that it will end in a
draw as the whole Queen side will get
traded down check yeah here they agree
to a draw not a very exciting game but
yeah it what it is what happens
sometimes um I think Giri wanted to play
something not as yeah well analyzed
maybe with queen bee three and Magnus
yeah it seemed to be as you seem to be
surprised as he took quite a while now
to check on c3 but he chose a very
pragmatic approach by the capture and
going c6 going back basically to to
classical knowledge out of this Laska
variation to trade down to complete
equality I think a good result for him
as he is leading the event and geary
would have won this game would have been
really in contention so i think carlton
is is happy with this result the next
game to check is in a vara with white
against Shakira mamedyarov we had a real
person and Momiji olive is going for g6
the same line that counts and had played
in an earlier round against kayaking so
sexually this is in fact a pretty decent
lawyer I really think so as I mentioned
already when I've made the video that
featured the kayaking card game my
objection yeah I guess this always was
as d4 takes Bishop g5 that I didn't like
especially I didn't like it in terms of
black playing for win and this is what I
would associate with the move g6 on on a
normal player level let's say that you
want something not so well explored and
so on
to surprise your point this is just not
very interesting that d4 takes Bishop g5
anyway this is probably on that level a
little bit too to bear in the position
so they go for c3 mostly end and play
this kind of position which always found
interesting for for both sides to play
well but yarrow here goes with age six
and in the cards in game Magnus metals
played nine f6 I think against against
kayaking after which we had d5 this who
should be three and te came up with that
funny Neji eight move yeah mama JAMA
place different the placement of age six
we are leaving himself got it c is
flexible now with his knights for
example if d5 is played this night can
go here and then you have c5 quickly
interesting idea yeah Navarro place not
be d2 it's an interesting interesting
concept yeah black now can take the pawn
and e5 now that looks very sharp but
Mammadyarov I think defense defense
defense at a fine fashion now g7 black
goes for development yeah note that
white is not so well developed this
whole night BTW 2 and so on it's all a
little bit slow took here castles yeah
now why tries to exploit that square on
f6 he goes night to you for check and
place 90 of 6 and this leads to some
sharp complications but the way it went
black could even take that pawn on f6
that's quite a funny funny move because
first idea is there to play G for now
and black it seems loses a piece however
this is a funny move 32 g 7 yeah saving
check check this is the point saving
material for black like this even of
course winning here if white would take
the night so g4 is bad but white can
take on h6 using the same pin
and a resulting position after all those
trades here is just completely equal
check we have a rook endgame ultimately
and chan with equal points that was
agreed to a draw so yeah some brief
excitement out are the opening here but
ultimately not that much happening the
next game we need to check because we
check all the games and I want to give a
full overview what happened it's again
Wesley so with right against Afghani
thomashefsky so it's going back to 1c
for what he had played earlier to be
Giri is mixing c4 ad for this event oh
yeah and thomashefsky in place the e5
classical stuff and after g3 plays the
move Knight to g4 this is an interesting
line that I'd like to recommend two
players that look for something to play
against one see form based on e5 if you
want something simple to play that's a
good line it's much easier to learn then
let's say a d5 here or Bishop to b4 as
after 94 wise choice is limited taking
on e5 is a very risky business after
Queen to e7 yeah white of course cannot
checkmate go back and has to play
something very uncomfortable like f4
here like this this this flex position
is pretty pretty nice so they all play
Bishop g2 we have to which plan takes
and now develops I know that looks like
1 2 3 like a loss of tempo but in the
meantime white also has moved with this
Bishop again and if we just look at the
position without counting any tempe we
see that both sides have two minor
pieces developed it should be completely
fine and black is not unhappy about that
trade as often yes this option of
playing c66 pretty similar to some kind
of italian game
yeah in turn in the game we saw this
interesting new bishop come in 26 but it
was back in the game quite quickly or
let's say back to a position where it's
not obstructing anything it is quite
funny that after Teague's she takes too
much let's keep playing c5 we now get
something that looks like a benoni but
it is a benoni that is pretty
comfortable for black because they're
already all Knights traded and peace
trades favor black in the Benoni because
black has a little bit less space and
this means that trading helps second
thing is quite often in the Benoni your
issue with black and said white plays
like efore f4e 5 breakthrough in the
center maybe at the end leading to some
kind of King side attack and this is
also not happening after the trade so
black can be happy there I think he has
equalised quite comfortably um yeah we
had this interesting we do Verruckt III
III but ultimately that only led to
trades yeah like ants no problems
whatsoever and black would like to push
his pawns but with that maneuver so has
prevented that and very wisely so if
they would have put the bishop back like
on g2 it would be very passive and here
I think white holds the balance
comfortably and a couple of more trades
but Luke ending just leads to yeah less
simplifications that here they agree to
a draw not a very exciting game but the
very correct game by them to basically
very solid players as mentioned that is
an interesting line to play for black if
you want something simple in the c forum
'if I've complex and the next game I'm
going to check is ding Liren with white
against Luke van Valley
and they went from a group felt yeah
ding is playing the Russian variation
with queen bee three as he did Ernie end
of event against my ears this seems to
be his main weapon against the
gruenfelder okay night a six by a van
Valen this is called the Prince
variation not like Prince them musician
from the 80s but it's PR i ns lodewijk
lodovic prince a dutch play and master
who has invented this line in the 19mm
like 50s or 60s been a while um and it
has some yeah it has some been a main
line of the queen bee three I'm
variation for quite quite a while um
Kasparov was is some maintenance main
protection petitioner in the 80s and 90s
even against Karpov in World
Championship matches okay black is going
C 5 that's the idea of 986 and this kind
of structure with whites d porn being
advanced is the typical picture of the
night a 6-line and the interesting thing
is that after some rather normal-looking
moves here yeah Queen B 6 technically no
novelty but it looks completely
completely normal that the next couple
of moves already lent ding into into
deep trouble yeah he plays the move with
3 which is yeah still seems to be okay
even though it's not quite so clear what
it does it covers the beep on maybe this
is a simple explanation but the move
after he ate here the move 92 this seems
to be um leading into trouble yeah white
had a couple of options for example
rookie one couple of moves that are
possible but this seems to lead to
trouble and we see quickly what happens
when really place the move 97 it took
him a long time
in this in the opening but we now see
the issue the night here I both get
towards the d3 square and whites queen
does not have many squares it is a
common problem in the Russian variation
here um yeah what's why it's supposed to
do maybe you look a 2d one what ding
play the rook see one I place rather
quickly and needs to deep trouble really
deep trouble when really plays this move
and this leads to a pretty clear edge
for black even though it seems that the
move Knight before it was even stronger
the intention is to just put the night
on d3 if we just look at a 3 which is
very cooperative but just to show the
idea black will jump here and after
takes for example there's 95 and black
isn't fantastic shape and the whole the
whole arm position is really bad night
before it's probably even stronger than
when various move even though he has a
prickly advantage she as well yeah rook
you one yeah if white takes black takes
something like this this is also very
awful the night on a force totally
misplaced and whites coordination is
very very bad yeah the there are threats
like simple threats like attacking this
Queen and then the rook will get the
bishop here yeah it's it's just it's no
fun this is what he did hook ft-1 and
again um here when really could have
cashed in if he if he sorry after this
actually not before nine and three here
he could have cashed in on c3 there is
no clear reason why he didn't do that it
wins in exchange um and probably that's
that's the way to play yeah whatever the
rook does it will always be taken
something like this for example black
hand and I can take and play
Queen to have six or something like that
yeah i know this is hanging and there
are some unclear spots in this line but
so it's an exchange and probably what
you should have done what he did is also
giving a clear view should be should be
a clear on that eh i gave the exchange
and got it right back so black one upon
with a very good position and instead of
taking on c1 the engine also gives the
move Queen GF 6 which is very strong
even though yeah taking the exchange is
fine there is nothing wrong with that so
we should not make the mistake of yeah
believing that you have to play or
should play one hundred percent
perfectly especially under time pressure
it is important to keep the advantage
it's not about some some digits there
okay I think what van really did is fine
yeah he kept his pawn was active
everything is good he now activated his
night and here we get to a critical
situation um he now takes on every year
and this is indeed a mysterious move
they both go down to roughly five
minutes and of course as I said you
cannot expect perfect play but the move
Knight B to D 3 was I think reasonably
easy to find the idea is that it doesn't
really matter if white takes on orbitz
here the thing the queen is attacked it
will move and then the move g-form and
if the night moves there is night f to
winning the rook and this is a yeah it's
a complete windfall for back for black
white can actually resign yet he will
lose we lose the house so that was a
very convincing way to win for when
really that he did not that it did not
take
really surprising it wasn't difficult
okay he took on f3 and now this was
taken and well if we count it's equal
material and black is maybe is still
somewhat active but the depot on you
know things are completely unclear now
in them further the cause of the game
there were some adventures here and
there but I don't want to get to to to
analyze it move by move the way it
happened actually why it was able to
sacrifice the Queen for a ton of
material ya hear check tags and here and
now the deep hole gets to be very
dangerous in fact with very little time
on the clock when really played Queen c3
allowing night of one and now the D porn
can only be stopped by a sacrifice and
here in this position of course black
has to fight for a draw I was to be
honest the next part of the game and it
lasts more than to any moves i only
checked somewhat superficially but i
think that there was no clear way to win
for for ding yeah answer now only white
who can do something um but i don't
think there was anything substantial
that he could have tried in fact i think
it's a pretty good job by FN really that
he didn't lose the game because he had a
completely winning position and the
worst part is he was certainly
completely aware that he was totally
winning and he had spoiled it and very
often if you were small your wind yeah
you're you don't spoil it just to a draw
but to a loss you know often in steps
yeah first you get it back to draw like
and then you lose yeah and he manages to
not lose this game chan got the h porn
up the board and now has this counter
play here they agree to draw already
because why it has no way to deal with
that age porn you can only block it yeah
with some
Bishop on the non bagging alike I think
this should this should work yeah and
Bishop and Luke yeah make sure that each
porn is not promoting same time there is
no way forward for for any side so draw
in this game a bit of a disappointment
certainly for event Valley who had a
wind at one point but easily after he
made him seems I've could have gone into
trouble and and lost a bit but he didn't
ok the next game to check is who you
found with white against alien off and
we get the Italian game which is getting
a juco piano which seems to be getting
more and more popular in this event we
saw on it we already saw it a number of
times and I an officer first player here
who goes for the setup that I'm actually
playing against Italian and yeah with a
six and Bishop to e6 I usually play
Bishop e7 a little bit earlier on he
does that later but I think that this
setup is very very decent from like yeah
who you find went Bishop see to not
trading always an interesting question
should wide trade that Bishop on on keep
it on the board the two versions there
white can trade herself here or let
black take I'm not sure you know of
course you can always do something like
that and allow the capture on b3 and
black whoever has a number of useful
moves like Bishop a 786 and so on um I
think that after Bishop see to that
keeps more pieces on the board and this
may be the more more fighting moving
away but still I believe that black is
very fine because he as we see in the
game age six ruki eight in d5 he gets in
d5 and the rule of thumb is if you can
get in d5
um in an opening like the Italian game
or the Ruto passing in mostly 45
structures you can get in d5 without
getting immediately punished technically
or your Center gets weak or something
like that if you can get it in without
any big issues then you normally find
that this I think applies here as well I
think a black should be about equal here
yeah what pushed on the queenside that's
an interesting idea but it got stopped
with b5 so further expansion is more
difficult now this is the position that
has been seen before internal practice
in a grandmaster game from bill on 2015
in an open event not in the master
tournament 94 was played very logical
looking move however also and pretty dry
move after something like this it looks
very dry now who you find went we should
be too looking a bit strange but she
wants to have this deform of as a
possibility later we are Queen to be 8
reroute in the Queen and now
centralizing yeah wyd took the bishop
here and now night h4 yeah this is an
interesting position that I think is is
roughly equal still however a couple of
moves later we come to a critical
position yeah black is scanning tried to
get some counter play here against
against f2 Queen to h5 Queens 8 yeah and
in this position why it has a number of
moves night f5 is an interesting option
Bishop f5 is interesting the move that
is questionable however is what we found
played she went for Bishop to you form
and this leads to trouble it really
leads to trouble after night afore the
queen is attacked and it doesn't have a
very good square don't forget that the
for part is also hanging now there's
quite some pressure on it yeah she went
to f3 and after this move now alien off
could have gotten a very very clear
advantage by taking one before that's a
nice tactic after the bishop capture
here when it takes 20 eggs and 93 and
this is absolutely devastating f2 is
attacked once twice three times e1 is
saying there's Bishop before as a threat
tons of threats now why term is in huge
trouble here the computer gives the wind
already so this was a big possibility
now if alien of taking on d4 you played
90 60 ever move that also looks very
attractive but it's not as strong after
this this is this he takes Bishop f3
black as a pawn up but it's not winning
immediately um the position still is
reasonably complicated and with both
sides getting a low on time in fact who
your phone again gets a chance to get a
decent game and this is after Bishop t4
here she could have taken on f5 and
taken on b5 here white is totally fine
after Bishop Taylor Bishop c6 for
example is yeah if anybody widest better
that was a chance for her but she didn't
play that after Bishop before she took
and now it took on d3 also very logical
looking continuation 92 check aha Luke
checks now you have to check Queen takes
gives away this
and Bishop takes Queen a saying so rook
takes group text III and this is a
critical moment now um who your fund
could have basically ended the game by
twin takes at five and ending it in a
draw Luke has to check take zombie five
and now black has to be very very
careful to not yeah give the a porn too
much oops too much scope here the apron
will be very very dangerous so um I'm
sorry it was a bit too much after this
black heads to take with the rook and
now looky a check in just seven Bishop
e2 gets the exchange back with a
completely equal position so this was
who your fans opportunity to equalize
the game however Allah said they were
both and very serious time pressure and
she at the end gave the check and played
this check after which the check and
another check kept the material for
black now alien office completely
winning and even though he made some
mistakes later and not did not find the
most forcing when it was never
completely in doubt as she continued to
fight but at the AI enough managed to
convert this position then one key idea
is to get rid of the ponds here and he
found a nice way of doing that this was
one
and this is an interesting movie I now
the sea pawn is running so white has to
basically take on puzzle after which the
a pawn gets liquidated and now that can
always operate with the idea of
returning the exchange at the right
moment together completely winning king
and porn ending so we're in for a lien
off a loss for hooli fun she had her
chances in this game at least to make a
draw but ultimately lost the game yeah I
think she an excellent start to the
event but now maybe is showing some
signs of the Anna no fatigue is the
right word but it is just probably very
difficult playing such a super high
level event if you are not used to this
kind of opposition on a daily basis she
has played those top players before of
course but doing that yeah day after day
after day is probably extremely
exhausting okay so the next game to
check is kayaking with white against
Mickey errors and again I'm happy to see
to say that Adams is playing one of my
openings so I'm always happy to see a
setup that I that I think a good and if
they are played by top players it's kind
of a yeah a nice confirmation that i was
thinking yeah i was on the right track
okk i Cain is playing the London system
which is getting really popular that
nowadays and Adams goes for this setup
this setup yeah this is a very sound
solid classical set up against the
London that I think is a very good
choice if you like those kind of central
based approaches um it is not something
that I had to recommend it in early
video series of mine a couple of years
ago I made a video series on how to
battle the London system in this series
I did not mention the setup I believe
but it is a very
and I said I'm very much recommended the
idea is that if white now takes on d6
and leg takes a black very likely
getting a five and this is of course
completely fine the black and white can
also go back to g3 this is what kayak
and it yeah and black castles and Bishop
b3 b6 yeah black is going for the
queenside fianchetto um here 95 was
played and this is also the main
continuation therefore white the idea is
that after Bishop to be seven wine is
going F form and switches this to a kind
of Stonewall it's an interesting form of
Stonewall because the bishop that
usually is sitting on c1 is now on g3
and sometimes can get to h4 to pin on
yeah otherwise be involved let's say
more than then from c1 um blacks ideas
this and played here by Adams the night
is coming over to f5 Queen a 390 a five
yr five it's a good square so blazer the
night is well positioned and after
Bishop f2 white is clearing the way for
the g4 push black plays the bishop back
and is now ready to put this night on d6
and then or black pieces that have some
kind of relevance for the e4 square are
geared towards that so black is ready to
occupy that outpost um okay I can plate
G for now sharp move quickly plate
though and he was still within his
preparation night to d6 and the g5 again
played very quickly and we see that the
London system is not super boring or
opening by default you can play it quite
ambitious day to be honest I have
a little bit in doubt that this is so
great this g5 stuff maybe I'm white yeah
should consider two to cancel shorty and
be a little bit more conservative one
thing I've really show of after g5
Knight f3 form and long castles what
kayaking played after some thought I
think that this is a serious yeah I
think it's a mistake to be honest um a
black play now is very simple yeah black
will play c4b five before just open up
the queenside as quickly as possible and
i'm not sure what whites ideas of course
he has gained some space and has a good
night but there is no direct way obvious
how is going to open up the position
while c4 and b5 is very very
straightforward yeah Adams when c4 yeah
don't be irritated by the clock he
didn't spend that long he spent quite
some time but the clock will jump back
to something more more logical yeah as a
black spawns start rolling and why does
not having a clear idea what to do he
went queen age three yeah black cannot
take me of course is made so I'm getting
out of this and still we see what black
is doing forward yeah very easy you just
yeah put everything against White's king
and white has no play you tried the
capture Adams captured as well of course
Bishop if one and now Bishop t5 yeah the
thing is if white eggs here a black is
going a five takes and just like giving
away everything to open up c3 Bishop
takes 95 a line like that for example is
terrible for water like here black has
given away material but his play is so
easy group c 8 or pieces participate in
the attack both bishops that's a
disaster like is winning him it's just
just a wind if white captures on before
it takes everything
yeah kayaking decided to play rook g1
but this of course allows me three it
was a matter of choosing between two
evils yeah okay okay it takes and Bishop
be one this is not a happy piece and
yeah here Adams um chose a somewhat
conservative approach may be also a
little bit due to his experience in this
tournament he played the f5 completely
trying to shut down any King side action
for white it seems that this was not
strictly necessary a move like group c 8
and probably would have led to get a
victory just by attacking White's
position and not caring so much what
white may have but still this is not to
be condemned black has a clear CH and at
the end I managed to win a very
convincing game the light comes to f5
and no black just have to get the pieces
near the king look here Queen a one now
so yeah it ends here on the SSC but in
fact they made a couple of mobile screen
be too kingi one hook t2 and here ki can
resign that this is that's what's the
official site gives us as moves so the
first written in this event for Micky
Adams who really suffered a lot gender
in this tournament I think it was on
minus four and a very heavy d future for
ki can who did not seem to be so
comfortable with the d4 Bishop f4 setups
as other players are you remember cards
it's a nice win against Tomashevsky um
this is a good opening for black if you
want a simple recipe against the london
system and especially if you with your
furthest moves are limited to a position
like that with d5 d6 sorry for that if
you're limited to that this is a very
serious option for black ok let's have a
look at the final game of this round to
check this is kiwana with white against
ye we gotta wait and ye is playing the
open variation the line that kawana has
played earlier in the event so they both
should know something about it yeah this
is the long-standing main position here
on with nine where white has tried a
couple of moves and the main line is not
be d to nowadays but the wood line is c3
it's played here um yeah but should be
seven here by by he Bishop c5 is also
main move and now somewhat less common
continuation by car 1i plays Bishop see
to that begitu where's the more and more
prominent move yeah Bishop g4 by the
Chinese player age three and Bishop age
five this was already played after a
long thought yeah Bishop takes f3m is
not really an option yeah I think after
take stakes and white seems to be in
good shape I mean it has been tried but
I don't feel like it's it's a very
attractive position for black therefore
white can also play before first both as
possible but I think white is better
here with this better central control
the king is somewhat weak but it's not
serious issue black's pieces are not
really near the king yeah I hate played
bishop h5 at the end and after g-form
bishop g6 and 94 the position got very
very sharp and we see that Karen has
blitzed out all this this is a very
important information he was completely
within his preparation I'm very very
very soon if you are black um 9085
is a move that can be checked here even
though after f4 probably why it seems to
be better and taking 25 against someone
who obviously has studied it inside out
it's probably not a good idea after this
this the position filled some yeah feels
very very murky but what I think is is
in good shape here and koala is the one
who knows that position much better than
his opponent it's just a possible idea
also alternatives at the end of ie
played Queen desalination he didn't dare
to take the corner however now after a
form takes takes an f5 I think white can
be quite happy here he must be somewhat
better because of his better central
control and more space it is not
necessarily terrible for black but wide
certainly has an opening advantage and
castles 93 yeah um here probably
probably on black should have taken on
c3 and played this position every takes
takes c6 something like that what is
better here and quite it so clearly
better it's not a substantial advantage
but it is clear that if anybody's valid
is white maybe this is why why he didn't
want to go for that it seemed too
one-sided to him however what he did he
played c6 immediately this leads to a
very clear advantage to what and in fact
in more than one way this is what koala
played and it is an advantage taking
what the night was also possible this is
looking really grim so d takes and now
Bishop and recheck Bishop f7 maybe and
now the question seems to be somewhat
better for white after rook takes Queen
B 3 for example yeah let's say Queen to
d5 rook c1 this pawn is not
particularly strong what kawana did is
taking with the bishop and this is also
a good continuation it's debatable
what's bad actually and this is again
bad so the dew point has to take and now
I push t5 um now and here black is in
trouble um the engines suggestion here
is to take on d5 and go for the endgame
but this is something that a human
player probably yeah once to avoid it
almost all costs it is just a terribly
passive position for black where one
mistake can cost you the game yeah so
quickly probably something like this and
just some centralizing move now rook to
d1 both rules look good ecigs is also
move yeah black black is in trouble but
it's maybe better than what he did you
played before and now after d takes the
recapture on c6 leads to an even worse
version of the endgame as before now I
saw the dark square this is why it took
1 D 1 but now after Knight takes the
position is to be honest winning for
what yeah the seaport is very strong and
the night is not active but will
ultimately be activated yeah here rook
e1 and I tf2 was maybe even even clearer
but what koala is doing is good enough
he has both his pawns light up and at
the end managed to convert this very
comfortably yeah here this was a nice
long shot Bishop takes before the point
is that after Bishop takes before there
was Luke c6 and now blanket or tank
because of the promotion he had to go
here and now f6 keeps all the material
for white he's a ton of pawns up and
after this year he resigned so this is
the first loss for the Chinese prodigy
in this event on round 10
in Rowan to 10 so he survived nine
rounds with the drawers and one win but
now ultimately got beaten in a game in
good style about heroin I think karana
got a good opening prep in with with a
good position out of the opening he
managed to put some pressure on where he
and he could not really defend this
properly very good game here by koala
after 10 rounds this means we have
basically a race between two players who
still can win the event we
mathematically speaking has been
probably more but Carson's leading with
the plus four score Caruana is trading
this was plus three so have a point
behind and the next players are I think
curious on +1 and restless always on
plus one day and this more than one
player so it's very likely that the
winner of this year's Tata Steel event
will be either magnus carlsen or fabiano
caruana they have played each other so
it's not a direct duel coming up but
we'll see in the next rounds on three
rounds left who ultimately will win this
first big important super tournament of
the year I hope you enjoyed the coverage
for around 10 I'll be back of course for
the final three rounds friday saturday
and sunday thanks for watching